tac tac tac on peut entrer
encore 1,15 piétiner la ville met en
scène lui-même je suis le père anselme
comment te bat corps et tu de moi leona
fulbert en salles le 12 nov colette une
autre personne qui ait les deux mêmes
prénoms accolé au nom mais la terre est
grande il y en a certainement cela
m'étonnerait je suis unique dans mon
genre ok c'est vrai
heureusement parce que 2 du 6 novembre
cela deviendrait insupportable et et que
désirez-vous illustre personnage est
bien le grand conseil de l'île aux
enfants a décidé de lancer une campagne
d'information sur la propreté
dans la propre les eaux la propreté mais
mais mais tout est propre messieurs du
challenge dans ligne dans cette maison
enfin
casimir et - n'arrêtons pas de faire le
ménage pour regarder ses sept quarts pas
de ça c'est pas prendre ça
oui c'est ça le problème presque
mais parlons de toi de moi mais oui
pourquoi moi parce que casimir n'est pas
là voyons ah oui ça c'est une raison
valable
effectivement alors trouvé deux fois par
jour de l'aveu tu les dents
[Musique]
tandis que je réfléchisse à une
fois mais c'est insuffisant léonard y
ont ils savaient les dents après le
petit déjeuner après le déjeuner après
le dîner roues aux premières nouvelles
nouvelles bon alors tous les combien te
fais tu un shampoing 1 une fois tous les
trois mois
juste enfin pour en renard il faut se
laver les cheveux au moins une fois par
semaine
oui c'est bon à savoir j'essaierai de
m'en souvenir bon enfin prends-tu
souvent un bâtard un
jamais au grand jamais ben baba
dépêche-toi léonard parce que pour en
renard vont prendre au moins un bain par
semaine
premièrement il n'y a pas une minute à
perdre on mais je vais m'y mettre
immédiatement se maintient en cadeau je
donne ce savant il est au bouton dans
ok luxe alors est-ce avons
[Musique]
dit que j'allais vous les avez jamais
vus journée que j'ai lu j'ai vu de mes
yeux vu je n'ai vu je vous dis que je
l'écrive et à mesure je l'est plus
aujourd'hui
quand il portait un grand chapeau vert
sera bâti sur les yeux
tous étaient tombés bleus moi je sais ce
que je dis c'est dit et une casquette
vous êtes désormais m'en fous ils
n'avaient rien sur la tête j'allais
jouer
jérémy de mes yeux vu je vous dis que je
n'ai jamais vu de mes yeux vu je les
joue dit que c'est lui les vingt
meilleurs jeunes m on dit que j'allais
vous j'ai rêvé d'un meilleur
il s'est sauvé en attendant une petite
faute ne plaisantons pas s'il vous plaît
c'était un gros qu'un art allons allons
il a volé un joli la grille vous dites
vraiment n'importe quoi c'était un
parapluie j'allais bujoli que je n'ai
toujours évident de revenir à lyon du
jour dit que j'avais vu son ebitda
meilleure vie je les ai vus jolie j'ai
jamais vu je lève le jury mais je n'ai
vu ses crédits dans le même but il est
parti à droite qu'il allait vers la
rivière non il a tourné à gauche du côté
de la guerrière il est partout tout
droit devant par un chant de prendre de
tels
[Musique]
jets
mes yeux vu jamais plus je vous dis que
j'ai lui telles mesures de gel et
aujourd'hui j'ai vu de mes yeux vu je
n'ai plus jamais dit que j'allais lui
même les yeux j'ai vu
vous allez bouger les huit de mes yeux
voilà oui oui oui et oui tout cela est
rien ah et les pieds au soir eh bien
tous les soirs tous les soirs mais c'est
merveilleux françois à vous est sans nul
doute possible l'habitant le plus
propres données nos enfants nous oublier
julie regardez-la en l'honneur de votre
campagne sur la propreté élastique son
kiosque el34 allons l'avoir voulez-vous
provost bravo julie bravo cube sera
propre comme un sou neuf
on dirait que son fief tahir de ce
manque est
possible
mais néanmoins garder tromper
mais effectivement on regardait ça vient
du trou de léonard mais les loups qui
continue à monter mais je ne peux pas
savoir d'où ça vient il faut que ça
s'arrête du calme nous avons raisonné
scientifiquement les enfants venaient
voir
venez
aimait bien vit avec nous julie je suis
en train de dessiner le sol de l'île aux
enfants ici julie voilà ton kiosque
tout en haut il y à la maison de casimir
et ceux ci c'est le tunnel qui relie la
malle de léonard
avec le kiosque de julie et sa des
sceaux oui oui mais écoutez je crois que
j'ai une idée venez avec moi
et voilà
on écoute léonard je commence à en avoir
assez pour la fête à rome iii son dos
que je verse dans ta mal on encore dans
ma baignoire casimir
ce n'est pas ma faute monsieur du genou
m'a dit de prendre un bon bain voilà le
d'accord mais enfin comment s'est-il
qu'elles ne sont pas encore remplies
elle est pourtant pas immense écoutes ne
pose pas de questions dont j'ignore la
réponse à diverses verse en battant j'en
prends un autre
c'est peut-être parce que tu es très
salah et qui se font rattraper tous les
battus aprilia allez encore un
c'est vraiment et un temps d'être
porteurs de 1 voilà bon alors alors le
manta non j'y comprends rien tu sais on
devrait essayer avec du lait d'ânesse il
paraît que c'est excellent pour l'impôt
du lait d'ânesse et puis quoi encore un
regard de moi moi je me lave avec l'eau
du robinet et pourtant j'ai la peau
douce comme un petit agneau
bon écoute j'ai une idée je vais
brancher directement le tuyau ça ira
plus vite j'espère
zik ouvre
alors ça marche
non non écoute c'est juste un tout petit
peu mouillé dans le fond
azimi je vais essayer de trouver une
baignoire d'accord d'accord puisque moi
aussi j'ai besoin d'un bon bain
tout a
souhaité tout à renault voilà je trouve
tout à tout un duel d'or
doubs tard
toute heure
oui tu me demandes
c'est moi
oc 3 tabac bah oui tu ne peux pas
frapper doucement comme tout le monde
c'est ta course de fous comme toi que
j'attrape des migraines mais [ __ ]
c'est le jour de mon histoire
c'est vrai où avais je la tête
bon aujourd'hui je vais te raconter
l'histoire l'histoire les citoyens du
lièvre et de la tortue
l'a déjà raconté la semaine dernière
depuis la semaine dernière tu as dû
l'oublier bon du tout pas du tout tu es
sur comment ça se fait bah tout
simplement parce que tu me la raconter
la semaine d'avant bon jeu mais j'adore
cette histoire
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
point
le lièvre et la tortue
en sont un témoignage
je ne m'en lasserai jamais
[Rires]
je n'en peux plus je crois je commence à
me faire vieux mes amis on enferme et et
je me reprocher reposez vous si vous
voulez mais pas sur mon dos vous allez
rayé ma carapace ont exclusivement
et laissez moi finir ma femme voilà on
vous voit raconte une fable oui laquelle
le lièvre et la tortue
encore plus fou que cela recommence pour
nous a non merci merci vous l'avez déjà
raconté plusieurs fois excusez moi je
suis très pressé en redemande maintenant
on va en croit le connaissais même pas
par coeur ses parts 1 vous oubliez votre
paquet monsieur martin martin
il est encore en cours évidemment
personne ne m'écoute jamais s'il avait
écouté ma femme il sort de rien ne sert
de courir mais qu'il faut partir à point
ces tuyaux d'arrosage dans la malle de
léonard qui comprend quelque chose toi
mais bien sûr julie est ce que j'avais
réfléchi une petite minute tu
comprendrais aussi c'est la réponse à
mon dessin de tout à l'heure
ton kiosque se trouve plus bas que la
maison de casimir donc le tunnel reliant
la malle de léonard à ton casque est en
pente et l'eau qui monte dans mon
kiosque via du tuyau d'arrosage de la
malle de léonard mais oui mais pourquoi
ont-ils fait ça alors là mystère ni
casimir ni les honneurs n'était là pour
me donner la réponse
regarde dans mon casque ça alors miss
ellie un arc fabrique
ouais
voilà
quinze mille boîtes voudrais tu me
frantic le dos et tacler avec la ram est
volontiers léonard
voilà
enfin pour affiner sa la place jean
léonard que fais tu dans mon kiosque
ça ne se voit pas je prends un
bar sort immédiatement de mon coeur est
vide le j'avais besoin pour prendre mes
buts mais il n'en est pas question suis
dit après c'est mon tour d'ailleurs ce
n'est plus un kiosque on regarde
jimmy
leona
[Musique]